August of 2,014,
the body of Tina Fontaine, 15 years old,
was discovered on the Red River.
She was wrapped in a blanket,
weighed down and thrown into the Red River.
And when the police announced her discovery,
the murder of this,
of this young girl,
for the first time in Winnipeg's history,
perhaps even across the country,
the lead investigator at the time,
I think one of the reporters had asked,
you know, like,
how do you feel about this?
And for the first time ever,
a police officer,
an investigator said,
well, she was a child.
We should all be enraged.
It was kind of the first time that you saw emotion,
but it was also
kind of the first time that you saw a police officer,
investigator,
a policing institution construct, um,
one of our missing and murdered as a child,
which she was.
And what that did was it galvanized
certainly the public in Manitoba,
but it also galvanized the public across the country.
Her little face,
her little innocent child face
was strewn all over media across the country.
And because of that,
there was this pressure on the government at the time
to call a national inquiry.
Michelle Audet was part of that.
A lot of us were a part of that.
There was lots of indigenous women and families
across the country
that were calling for a national inquiry.
In December of 2,014,
the former prime minister,
Stephen Harper,
was interviewed by Peter Mansbridge
and Peter Mansbridge said to him,
you're getting a lot of pressure.
Are you looking at a national inquiry?
And the prime minister of Canada at that time said,
well, honestly,
it's not on our radar at this time.
We'll have some ministers
talk to people that are concerned about this issue.
In February of 2,015,
because of that,
because of Tina Fontaine,
because of those cold and callous
words from a sitting prime minister
that was pressured to hold the first ever national
round Table
that was held in February of 2,015.
It was here
held here actually in Ottawa.
It was the first time that Canada
uh, and provinces and territories and indigenous um,
uh, N a O's sat together alongside
uh, m, m, I, W, G
families and uh,
indigenous women activists was the first time ever.
At that meeting
if you will recall
around that same time,
the minister responsible for Aboriginal affairs
was a man by the name of Bernard Del Gore.
And what did he say
during all this time that was going on
Tina calls for national inquiry.
What did he say?
He said, well,
70% of the murders,
the people that do the murders and steal
indigenous women are done by indigenous men.
That was very intentional.
It was intentional
because he was trying to blame indigenous peoples and,
and minimize the systemic system,
systemic racism and systemic misogyny and anti
indigenous racism
so that it made Canada not culpable for what's going On
across the country
um fast forward to October 2,015
there's a change in government
there was an active um
coordination from families and indigenous women
to push the new government to call a national inquiry
December, I think it was December 5th or 6
uh 2 thousand uh
15 the new uh
federal government calls a national inquiry
and February 2,016 was the second national
round table on missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls
we hosted it in Manitoba.
We had almost
I I can't remember and
and one of my colleagues that helped me uh
coordinate that
I think we had like 350
m m I W G 2 s families
and and uh uh
premiers and ministers
we had um all kinds of MPs attend that
and we started this work in a really good way
with the new government.
We gave out
we gifted blankets to the families
um Carolyn Bennett sat in circle
uh with m m I W
G2 s families.
I think we were there until midnight.
We had a sharing circle
uh the national inquiry of course
why am I saying all of this?
I'm saying all of this
because I understand the frustration
but I also want us to
to remember and to recognize
that work is happening
and what's the theme
between all of that
and where we are today
is our women
is m m I W G2S families
it is our women
and m m I W
G2S Families
that have paved the way,
planted the seeds,
did the work with blood,
sweat and tears
so that we are sitting here in 2,024
with the most ministers
that have ever come to a round table
with a new minister.
And this is,
listen, I, I'm an NDP.
I'm not to, you know,
to trying to prop up the Liberal government.
But I do want to give props where props are deserved.
We have a minister
who has sat with us on and off.
He's a little bit busy,
but sat with us for 48 hours
and has reiterated his commitment
to making things right
and to doing this work.
So I, I just wanna say that,
that, I know it's frustrating, but we,
but we are moving in the right direction. And,
and a perfect example of that,
and this is my final comment,
is Haley Rose,
Tyler, George
and Samantha, Jack.
These young ones are our future.
You are our future leaders.
And it is an honor to sit at this table
with each and every one of you.
All of us at the table are so impressed with you.
And we want you to know that we support you
and we love you. Thank you.